we have this many body Quantum system
and uh we can only view sort of bits and
pieces of it at a time that's the bad
news the good news is that we can
utilize superposition and interference
between uh the states of these systems
but in order to be able to solve things
faster than uh than classical computers
this type of structure is only amenable
to certain problems
there's a table here you could make that
lists the tasks and you can organize
them in terms of whether they're useful
in the real world whether they are
exponentially faster now by exponential
I mean exponentially in the number of
qubits so you have a family of problems
Each of which has a certain size you
want to sort n equals two objects three
objects four objects five objects where
you're a traveling salesman and you want
to visit n equals two destinations three
destinations four destinations five
destinations the time it takes you to
figure out optimal way to visit all of
them scales with the number of
destinations because if you have two
destinations you can you know how to do
that but if you have 17 it's it's going
to be a lot harder right and how does
the the time it takes for you to figure
out what's the best way for you to cover
all 17 destinations scales with seven
with the number of destinations you're
trying to cover and the third part is
have they been realized meaning have
they been in some part built in the lab
so the first task that quantum computers
are famous for is factoring numbers
factoring large numbers is what allows
you to break your your bank so by large
numbers I mean 100 digits thousand
digits definitely useful supposed to be
faster uh so you're supposed to be able
to do this faster in a quantum computer
but even that in fact we don't really
know because people in complexity Theory
people who determine how fast everything
is uh don't actually that they haven't
actually proven a lot of things a lot of
this stuff is conjecture but uh the the
logic is that lots of smart people have
tried and so there's a sort of belief
that the factoring large numbers
generally is going to be fast uh done
faster on the quantum computer than it's
possible to do in a classical computer
now P equals NP is this little caveat so
assuming that these two things aren't
equal so this p is basically stuff you
can do you can do this stuff on a
classical computer pretty easily and and
this stuff here is believed not to be
doable so as long as this is true then
everything is fine so large numbers have
not been realized in the lab okay 15
doesn't count now there's another class
of
like I said this NP problem so these are
supposed to be hard on a classical
computer
and complete just means any prop they're
all kind of related to each other very
useful traveling salesman is one of
these they are not believed to be doable
faster on a quantum computer again as
with the caveat that certain conjectures
and stuff are satisfied and they have
been realized you can try to realize
things that you're not going to be able
to do faster just to show that you can
do something with your device but it's
not going to necessarily give you a
speed up now one of the oldest tasks
that quantum computers are supposed to
be useful for is simulation so
um I mentioned maybe in the previous
lecture that
a quantum computer is a Quantum system
and so is a molecule so is a material so
is uh some high energy set of high
energy particles that are colliding with
each other
and we can use our engineered Quantum
system to simulate a Quantum system we
want to know more about that we can't
otherwise realize in an easy way like a
protein or a material or some set of
high energy particles that are colliding
with each other so definitely useful can
Quantum simulation be done faster on a
quantum computer than in a classical
computer people believe so this
basically just boils down to the idea
that the stuff you can do using
classical physics and randomness
classical computers and Randomness is
not the same or smaller in some sensor
doesn't contain problems that you can do
with quantum computers and Randomness
and again this is not something we
really you know there's no Smoking Gun
here it's it's sort of a general uh
belief and uh small systems and maybe
even relatively larger ones recently
have been realized on Quantum devices
now have they given us new physics yes
there's certain cases where we have
learned new physics about Quantum system
uh have they helped us solve you know
determine useful properties that we
hadn't known before that we were able to
adapt to the real world and help solve
real world problems no I would say no
that we haven't been able to go that far
but we're on our the hope is that we're
scaling up and making our devices more
uh robust and less fragile and
eventually we hope to get to a large
enough system size so we can actually
spit out solutions that are useful for
the real for for the for the parts of
these problems that are indeed useful
for the real world and then the rest of
the algorithms there's a lot of
different Quantum algorithms and I'm not
doing Justice by kind of shuffling all
of them into this this one less the one
next entry in the table but I did just
want to peel off the three kind of
important ones showing that there is
something quantum computers are
purportedly going to do well that we
can't do well yet there are things that
they can't do well that we can try to
use them for but we're not gonna we're
just not gonna probably gain a lot from
that there's something that they're
supposed to be doing well in terms of
simulating Nature and that's probably
one of the main applications down the
road and then there's a lot of different
algorithms some of them are useful uh
but maybe won't run faster it's not
clear they're heuristics and some of
them are uh
not that they do run faster but it's not
clear how useful they are so basically
you have this trade-off between faster
and useful for most classical algorithms
and sort of the the one that's really
you know Smoking Gun as smoking as it
can get for both useful and faster is
factoring and these of course have also
been in small instances realized on
devices now
the types of devices that that I
mentioned using atoms ions photons
Electronics they are
beginning to be scaled up to hundreds of
qubits but
and in a way that we are able to try to
maintain the fragile Quantum properties
that allows us to utilize effects of
collapse superposition uncertainty and
entanglement however they're still too
noisy to be able to do really precise
computations and uh this era of of
scaling up to these noisy Quantum
devices is called the nisk era in our
community and this is the era of noisy
intermediate scale quantum
and all of these devices so far are nisk
and in order to really utilize them for
super precise computations that actually
output you know specific numbers that
have to be you know 10 bits of precision
20 bits of precision we really have to
make them more robust and utilize extra
overhead of encoding information
redundantly in processed information
redundantly using error correction
applying gates in a way that taught is
tolerant to errors namely it's called
fault tolerance
and we also should pick we also tried
should try to outline other problems
that have the right type of structure to
be able to be utilized with Quantum
interference and harnessed with quantum
computers in a way that's faster and and
so this area is very much active right
now and it's very exciting to watch
these algorithms develop
we see these waves matter behaves like a
wave when you get down to the atomic
level which means that all of the here
uh if you even consider thinking of it
as a wave which we can you know you
don't even have a single wavelength fit
in here you